the dream is
dead pour one out grieve bid farewell to
the croissance or croissance for short
that never was Chris Christie is dropped
out of the 2024 presidential race
christe's announcement came just hours
before the final primary debate before
the Iowa caucuses but if you were
expecting an endorsement some signal
from the candidate as to where christe's
supporter should redirect his vote you
will be disappointed because Christie
capped off his concession with a parting
shot at both of his remaining rivals in
the race all caught on a supposedly hot
mic they don't want to hear it we know
we're right but they don't want to hear
it and and there's you know we couldn't
have been any clearer right we couldn't
have been any more any more direct or
worked any harder so and let forget she
spent $68 million yeah I mean we spent
well when you give land to China and
places like that yeah that's what you
get yeah yeah I mean look she spent 68
million so far just on TV spent 68
million so far 59 million by D santis
and we spent 12 I mean who's punching
above their weight and who's getting a
return on their investment you know and
she's going to get smoked and you and I
both know it she's not up to this she
hasn't even she's still 20 points behind
Trump in New Hampshire right yeah and
he's going to he's still going to carry
out right yes oh he's I you I talk to
DeSantis called
me petrified that I would he's probably
getting out
half whoa where did that tape come from
what a what an amazingly convenient leak
where Christy sounds totally articulate
and gets across all of the vindictive
points he wants to make in the race and
then it cuts off right before he could
spill a little bit of tea and uh in any
case Christie's not endorsing either of
these people these were tough words
followed by a tough debate so
how will this major political news
affect the polls which have Trump 52
points up on everyone polls which
basically haven't changed in in 17
months they've just stayed pretty much
exactly the same with the entire rest of
the field combined still not equaling
Trump's support stay tuned for the
shocking answer as to how all of this
will affect the
race it won't I'm Michael nolles this is
the Michael NS show
[Music]
welcome back to the show I probably
should have given a spoiler alert there
before I thought it was so obvious
though that it won't it won't it won't
affect anything we'll go through the
debate very briefly then we will get to
the question question that is on
everyone's mind the question that a
reporter just asked Hunter Biden on
Capitol Hill yesterday namely his crack
preferences first though I watched the
debate there I guess there were three
debates there four candidates left in
the race Trump
vake Ronda santis and Nikki
Haley the people who qualified for the
CNN debate are Chris Christie who
dropped out hours before Nikki Haley
Ronda santis and Donald Trump trump
decided not to show up the did not
qualify for the CNN debate so the said
okay well whatever I'm going to go do a
show with Tim p and Candace Owens and my
show with them is probably going to get
way better ratings than the debate and
it probably that will turn out to be
true was certainly more
interesting then Trump went and did his
own town hall because the entire rest of
the field combined still doesn't reach
his poll numbers so he says there's no
reason for him to to show up to one of
these debates because it's it's all risk
it's all downside there's no potential
upside really and that that left Ronda
santis and Nikki Haley who are now tied
for number two in the race but they're a
distant number two this is way way far
behind they're going to either have to
throw Trump into prison well even that
wouldn't be enough because he could
still be on the ballot from prison like
Eugene Debs the Socialist candidate a
100 years ago so they'd have to kill him
so short of Donald Trump being killed or
totally
incapacitated uh these guys don't really
have a much of a shot in the race but
they showed up anyway good on them we've
got the highlights
santis the top line I think is that
DeSantis performed very well on
substance I think he won the debate on
substance I don't think he quite had the
style that is persuasive to people so I
think that Nikki Haley broadly won on
style though she had a few missteps
there as well but on the substance Ronda
santis came locked and loaded he hit
Nikki Haley for being a squish he said
that she marked
with the blmr and if not literally at
least in rhetoric that she bought into
the leftwing talking points of the last
three five years and the conservatives
can't trust her Nikki Haley and I have a
disagreement on the BLM stuff too
because she tweeted during this period
of time that the death of George Floyd
should be quote personal and painful for
each and every American but people in
Iowa had nothing to do with that or
Florida or South Carolina she was virtue
signaling to the left she was accepting
The Narrative uh and she was trying to
impress people who are never going to
like us I never bought in to going after
the police we back the blue to the Hill
State of Florida and we're we're we're
have lower crime as a result of that
thank you Governor Haley it's a good hit
it was a nice attack especially in Iowa
which is pretty conservative Place Dan
santis then keeps it up he hits Haley on
illegal immigration he says that
immigration is one of the biggest issues
for any conservative voter and Nikki
Haley cannot be trusted because she's
bankrolled by the people who support
Mass migration do not trust Nikki Haley
with illegal immigration that's like
having the fox guard the hen house she's
on tape at the Asen Institute she'll say
she didn't say it she was chastising
conservatives saying it's disrespectful
to illegal aliens to say that they're
criminals they're violating the law it's
disrespectful when people come to this
country illegally and impose burdens on
our communities and run drugs into this
country that's what's disrespectful
she's weak on imig ation she's
bankrolled by people who want open
borders and she said there shouldn't be
a limit on immigration you should work
with corporate CEOs that is pale pastels
that warmed over so Governor Haley you
see what I'm talking about when I talk
about the substance and the style if you
just read a transcript of that attack it
was basically Flawless it was it was
well written but when DeSantis gave it
it it
sounds kind of whiny it's sounds almost
whatever the male equivalent of shrill
is go that's not can
you and which is fine if he were just
having an academic debate even or if he
were talking into a microphone on a
podcast or radio show or if he
were communicating with a friend over a
drink but on the presidential debate
stage it it doesn't seem quite as
persuasive it doesn't seem quite as in
control and I think Nikki Haley did a
great job in that regard Nikki Haley
seems in control even even when Dan
santis has her dead to rights on some
issue she kind of talks her way out of
it I think that helps to explain some of
her rise in the polls at least in places
like New Hampshire she overplayed one
rhetorical bit a lot last night before
the debate her campaign had set up
DeSantis lies.com and it was a fine
little campaign trick so she said oh go
to DeSantis lies and you'll see why what
he just said isn't true but she
overplayed it I mean she she took the
the marketing advice to just constantly
be getting your brand out there way way
too far and so virtually every answer
she gave she would just say go to
DeSantis lies.com but that that really
wasn't that persuasive because you want
your candidate to be quick on his or her
feet and to be able to explain in the
moment why what someone said isn't true
uh so so that was a little bit of a
crutch but overall on substance she
still seemed more in control the one
area where they they both agreed was on
Israel policy so it it became a debate
of who is more pro-israel who's more
willing to give the Israeli government
just a blank check to do whatever they
want uh the irony of this is that while
Israel is currently a somewhat
controversial issue on the right uh the
candidates on stage were totally in lock
step and and the only person who was
even in that Auditorium who was somewhat
shaky on Israel was Jake Tapper Jake
Tapper who said would you support the
mass removal of Palestinians from Gaza
and the candidates danced around the
question but they seem to suggest yes
they would uh the takeaway from this I
think is that no matter what kind of
debates you hear breaking out in the
commentariat OR on Twitter or
wherever Israel's support remains very
very strong among the GOP if these
candidates thought
that the the base were anti-israel they
would have said that during the debate
last night if if these candidates
believed
that going a little weaker on Israel
would win them a single extra vote they
they might have considered doing that so
it's true the left is now totally split
on Israel the base profoundly
anti-israel the donor class and the
establishment much more pro-israel for
the GOP though whatever the debates are
in the commentar at and online
that might have been the one area last
night where the two of these people
totally agreed and then they made their
closing statements which reminded us
that we could have avoided the entire
debate because their candid candidacies
come down to really basic pitches that
they've been making the whole time not
necessarily policy now when you want to
talk about policy you got to check out
policy genius right now go to policy
genius.com start the new year off
knowing you found the right life
insurance to protect your family with
policy genius policy genius makes it
easy to compare life insurance quotes
from top companies and find your lowest
price their licensed agents work for you
not for the insurance companies that
means you can trust their guidance
because they don't have a financial
incentive to recommend one insurer over
another there are no added fees your
personal information is kept private
it's really really important to have
life insurance some of us at different
times have been caught in tough
situations because family members I did
not necessarily have life insurance so
make sure you do the responsible thing
for your kids it is super satisfying to
check life insurance off that to-do list
then you don't need to think about it
anymore a good life insurance plan can
give you peace of mind that if something
happens to you your family will be able
to cover mortgage payments College costs
and other expenses life insurance
through your workplace may not offer
enough protection for your family's
needs it won't follow you if you leave
your job since life insurance typically
it's more expensive as we age Now's the
Time to buy policy genius makes the
process much much easier with policy
genius you can find life insurance that
start at just $292 per year for $1
million worth of coverage some options
offer same day approval and avoid
unnecessary medical exams save time and
money give your family a financial
safety net with policy genius
policygenius.com click the link in the
description get your free life insurance
quote see how much you could save
policygenius.com
Nikki Haley makes your closing statement
we can't go through another nailbiter of
an election and if you look at the polls
right now going against Joe Biden in
every one of those head-to-head polls
Ron doesn't beat Joe Biden Trump is
head-to-head on a good day he might be
up by two points I defeat Biden by 17
points that's a that's bigger than the
presidency that's house that's Senate
that's governorships that's down the
school board that's a mandate to get our
spending under control and get inflation
down that's a mandate to get our kids
reading again and go back to the basics
in education that's a mandate to secure
our borders with no more excuses that's
a mandate to bring Law and Order back to
our country and that's a mandate for a
strong America that we can be proud of
we can do this I know we can do this if
you will join with me in this movement
if you join with me in this fight I
promise you our best days are to come
okay simple enough pitch she says if you
talk to the consultants and you look at
the polls in a general election I
trounce Joe Biden no one else even comes
close now I don't think that all the
polls are wrong I think it's easy enough
to skew a poll or two especially if
you're talking about Five Points maybe
10 points maybe 15 points I am persuaded
by say the presidential nomination polls
from like real clear politics because
it's very difficult to skew all of the
polls by 50 points so I do think that
Trump is clearly the front runner here
but why might I be a little bit
skeptical of the polls that Nikki is
citing here well because Nikki doesn't
have anywhere near the same name
recognition that someone like Donald
Trump does uh she has not been smeared
nearly as much as Trump has by the
Democrats that would happen if she if
she were to win the nomination and so I
think you would see that
17o margin of Victory even if it's real
that would diminish very very quickly
the minute that the Democrats train
their guns on her and her name got out
there maybe she would still have a
better shot of beating Biden than Trump
but I'm not so sure because Nikki's
pitch is I'm the more moderate candidate
I'm the more Centrist candidate I have
appeal to to more moderate people that
the current conservative wing of the GOP
can't can't win
over I don't know that the history of
presidential politics bears that out
Mitt Romney made that pitch Mitt Romney
lost John McCain made that pitch John
McCain lost now you you could say well
they both lost to Barack Obama he was a
singular left-wing political Talent so
that doesn't that doesn't hold okay what
about Bob Dole Bob Dole was pretty
moderate much more moderate than other
candidates in the race and he lost to
Bill Clinton well Bill Clinton was kind
of moderate too okay uh George HW Bush
George HW Bush was pretty moderate he
also lost to Bill Clinton okay Ronald
Reagan was the conservative he ran as
the conservative in that race he won two
terms what about before that uh Jerry
Ford much more moderate Jerry Ford is a
one- termer and you you can always point
to other historical circumstances you
say well it's because he pardoned Nixon
well it's because of this well it's
because of that yeah maybe I just don't
believe that the moderate pitch is what
wins on the left
too do you think Barack Obama ran as the
moderate he didn't Barack Obama is the
dominant Democrat politician of our
lifetime so that's her pitch in any case
it might be persuasive to some people
here's desantis's pitch we have an
opportunity in Monday to really change
the course of history Donald Trump's
running for his issues uh Nikki Haley's
running for her donor's issues I'm
running for your issues your family's
issues and solely to turn this country
around I'm the only one running that's
delivered on 100% of my promises uh and
I'm the only one running that has beaten
the left time and time again from the
teachers unions to fouchy to the
Democratic party we need to run under
the banner of bold colors that are
putting the American people first we
can't run under a banner of pale pastels
of of the warmed over corporatism the
likes of which is practiced by Nikki
Haley okay I I like this pitch a lot I
like this image of we need vibrant
colors not the pale pastels of warmed
over corporatism I don't know that the
line works that well it certainly speaks
to me though I like that a
lot he his initial attack is probably a
pretty good framing for his campaign he
says Trump is running for his vindictive
personal issues Nikki is running to do
the bidding of her Don on Wall Street
and I'm running for you I'm not sure
that that's totally fair by the way I
think Donald Trump has in this way
rightly been called a populist in that
he has spoken to issues that matter to
the American people that have been
ignored for 30 years of Republican
politics he spoke to
those kitchen table issues okay meat and
potatoes issues Common Sense kind of
issues that were ignored by the elite
class in the Beltway and on Wall Street
and everywhere and in the commentary and
every everywhere else Trump spoke to
that so I think it's but it it's
probably a good framing same thing with
the Nikki attack she does the bidding of
her donors yeah sure I'm sure she does I
think all politicians basically do the
bidding of their donors but they attract
certain donors because they have certain
views so which is it the chicken or the
egg Dan santis is insinuating that she's
a prostitute who will do whatever to the
highest paying customer but I'm not sure
of that there are maybe not as many but
still a number of very powerful wealthy
right-wing donors conservative
right-wing Rock ribbed donors who aren't
giving to Nikki Haley because she's not
offering them what they want
so a fine attack it resonates for
someone like
me what is it really matter though what
does it really matter I I it was it was
a hard night I think for the disantis
campaign and less so for the Haley
campaign
because I don't think anyone really
believes that that debate is going to
change anything how what's it going to
change even if you're the biggest Ronda
Sanz fan ever you're the biggest Nikki
Haley fan what's that debate going to
change all of a sudden all of a sudden
you're going to go from 17 months of
polls basically it totally even the only
thing that's changed is Trump's Rivals
have gone down a little bit and Trump's
Trump personally has gone up a little
bit all of a sudden it's just going to
totally flip all of the polls everywhere
in the country I just don't really buy
that if I if I were on the STIs campaign
I would be disappointed because the
guy's a good candidate in other years he
is is a great Governor he's far more
right-wing than a lot of politicians
we've seen in recent years but the
campaign made a miscalculation and they
ran against a guy who whose popularity
they underestimated the Loyalty of whose
base they underestimated and who's
running effectively as an incumbent even
though he doesn't he's not technically
an incumbent but practically he is and a
popular incumbent at that so Trump
doesn't even show up he goes and does a
town hall separately with Brett Bear and
Martha mcallum and just to Twist the
knife in the other campaigns he floats a
little bit of Juicy tea who would be in
the running for a vice president well I
can't tell you that really I mean I know
who it's going to be you give us a hand
I'll give you we'll do another show
sometime what about any of the people
who you've run against would you be open
to mending fences with I will I will
I've already started like Christy
better christe Christie for vice
president I I don't see it I don't see
it that would be an upset Christie for
vice president you know and gentlemen
I'd like to
announce just he's just having fun at
this point has Donald Trump picked his
VP I don't know he says he has but has
he I don't know or is he just saying
that because he knows that if he say
says that that comment is going to get
more play in the
media than anything that was said at the
official GOP Primary
debate which certainly is the case
what's the viral clip from the GOP
Primary debate between Ronda santis and
Nikki
Haley it really isn't
one but a lot of people are talking
about oh who is he going to pick for VP
and then he's having fun with it is it
going to be you know I kind of like
Christia already I like him more because
he dropped out that loser I hate him no
no I like him what do you think should I
pick him for VP you think that's going
to work VP Chris I I don't know I don't
know about that he's just he's just up
there joking around because he's that
confident that he's going to get the
nomination and who knows something crazy
could happen maybe disantis pulls an
upset in Iowa Could
Happen even
then when was the last time Iowa picked
the GOP nominee it's George W bush 20
years
ago
and then what maybe Nikki Haley pulls an
upset in New Hampshire maybe probably
not but maybe she does and then what and
then what it's just such an uphill
battle
now speaking of trump being the center
of
attention uh the democrat congress lady
prila
jaipal is is really honing in on the
attack for Donald Trump Assuming he's
going to be the nominee they're going to
say this guy is an ins tionist he's a
threat to the country but they can't
even say it with a straight face well I
appreciate the passion from my friend
across the aisle and the outrage I think
we're all outraged about many things but
if we're going to talk about outrageous
things that have happened or things that
have never happened let's talk about the
fact that President Trump incited an
erection an maybe that
too yeah you could talk about that too I
guess maybe we should talk about that
too the president inside Ed an
Insurrection maybe we should talk about
the fact that the president the former
president was impeached twice maybe we
should talk about the fact that the
former president was convicted on 91
felony counts she can't stop laughing
even as she's saying this unless talking
no no come on come on prila get it
together uh even you know he
uh he was indicted on all these
Trump's
erection they can't keep a straight face
and it's not just because of the
Freudian slip there they can't keep a
straight face because it's Preposterous
because nobody thinks that Donald Trump
is Jefferson Davis nobody thinks that
he's going to lead a coupa and overthrow
the government and everyone knows it's
ridiculous he's the Tabloid real estate
guy from the 80s he's the host of the
really popular Network TV show The
Apprentice he's the guy who has stakes
in vodka and board games he's not he's
Trump okay he's the guy who was already
president and left office peacefully and
transferred it's just none of
it No One Believes it they say it the LI
but the libs say a lot of things they
don't believe they say that a man is a
woman okay they they and they do their
best to keep a straight face W when it
comes to Trump it's very difficult to
keep a straight face now one way they've
tried to get Trump is they try to audit
as companies and uh when you are facing
tax problems you got to check out tax
Network right now go to TN
usa.com are you struggling with back
taxes or have unfiled returns this year
the IRS is escalating collections by
adding 20,000 new agents in these
challenging times your best defense is
to use tax Network USA with over 14
years of experience tax Network USA has
saved their clients over $1 billion doar
in back taxes they specialize in
negotiating with the IRS and aim to
reduce your debt significantly tax
Network USA does not just negotiate they
protect your assets from IRS seizures
and manage your yearly returns for
ongoing compliance importantly they are
licensed to help with all state tax
issues regardless of where you live in
the US seize control of your financial
future now and don't let tax issues
overpower you contact tax Network USA
for immediate relief and expert guidance
call 1 1800
245 6000 or visit
TN
usa.com letter T letter N
usa.com turn to tax Network USA and find
your path to financial peace of mind
speaking of Shenanigans in
Congress Hunter Biden showed up and this
is great hunter Biden first showed up to
the capital some weeks ago but he
wouldn't go in he didn't want to
actually testify he just held a big
press conference outside this time he's
gone in he still won't go to the closed
door testimony that he's required to do
but he shows up and he says he'll he'll
speak publicly and the Republicans go
after him in kind of strange ways
chairman comr um first all my first
question is who brought Hunter Biden to
be here today that's my first question
um second question you are the epitome
of white privilege coming into the
oversight committee spitting in our face
ignoring a congressional subpoena to be
deposed what are you afraid of you have
no balls to come up here and Mr chairman
point of inquiry Mr chairman um recogniz
if the G if the G lady wants to hear
from Hunter Biden we can hear from him
right now Mr chairman let's take a vote
and hear from Hunter bid what are
you
on allowed to speak in here or no are
women allowed to speak in here or no you
keep interrupting me I'll interrupt the
chair interrup know that he's a
lady I think that uh that Hunter Biden
should be arrested right here right now
and go straight to jail our nation is
founded on the rule of
law this is so
depressing it's so depressing because
this is the Republican this is the
conservative and she's got this
opportunity to really go after Hunter
Biden The Bag Man for the Biden family
that this guy who is the tip of the
Spear of Biden corruption and the way
she does it is by regurgitating a bunch
of far-left talking
points what are her attacks on Hunter
Biden are her attacks that he's a
derelict who behaves in a in a vicious
way who's faced no consequences for his
personal crimes and that he is the
representative of the major political
crimes of his family his father who
pedal American influence all around the
world and profited from it is that it no
her attack is you're a white man you
white man you have white privilege
Hunter Biden does not have white
privilege if Hunter Biden had white
privilege then when he applied to
college he would have been discriminated
against by the admissions board he would
have lost effectively lost points on his
SAT score because of the color of his
skin if Hunter Biden had white
privilege he would have been excoriated
he would have been punished more harshly
for transgressions he hasn't been
punished at all
he would have been regularly uh reviled
and insulted not only as a a matter of
of law but even as a matter
of social
norms because white people are the only
people in the country that you are
permitted legally to discriminate
against and also encouraged socially to
discriminate
against okay White Privilege are you
kidding me this is what we this is what
we get for electing Republicans and
conservatives we get to
hear invectives about the evil white man
from Congress oh great with Republicans
like this who needs Democrats and then
when they rightly tell her yo lady give
it a rest she says are women not allowed
to talk so then she she flips she she
stops pushing the race hustling uh
phrases of the left and she switches to
the feminist phrases of the left I'm a
woman and the men aren't letting me
speak vote for Republicans so you can
get more girl boss f talking points in
Congress oh oh it's so it's so pathetic
it's awful it's
awful
ah what
a what a what a black pill as the kids
call it this is this and why is this
happening
because liberalism is the water in which
we little fish swim liberalism is the
air that we breathe it's because we
become so habituated to the language of
the left that we internalize it and it
doesn't just Lodge itself in some corner
of our brain it actually forms our
Consciousness in the way that we
perceive the world it's because if you
can control words you can control minds
as I point out in my number one
bestselling book speechless controlling
words controlling it's available now for
for order even couple of years after it
was published I I think this is proof
positive it's just so of all the things
to attack Hunter Biden for
being a white guy is pretty low on the
list and of all the reasons to complain
about the way Congress
operates to say it's because we don't
let women speak enough oh good grief
Lady it's just awful now margorie Taylor
green had a better line of questioning
against Hunter Biden so much so that he
stormed out of the capital CH recognize
Miss Green from Georgia for five
minutes thank you Mr chairman uh excuse
me Hunter apparently you're afraid of my
words
oh I'd like to reclaim my time Mr
chairman burst their
bubble wow that's too
bad Rec from I think it's clear and
obvious for everyone watching this
hearing today that Hunter Biden is
terrified of strong Conservative
Republican women because he can't even
face my words as I was about to speak to
him what a coward even margerie I don't
want to knock her too much for this even
Margery starts to take on these feminist
talking points and she is Far and Away
the best Republican in this
exchange but even she even you got Nancy
mace who does the white men are evil and
I'm a girl boss and women aren't heard
and this is a patriarchy and she even
she uses naughty language like you know
I'm not a regular Congress lady I'm a
cool Congress lady I'm going to use
naughty vulgar language that if a
seventh grader used it in a classroom
he'd be yelled at but me I'm cool so I'm
going to break all Norms of Civility
yeah I'm cool doesn't that make me cool
I'm like cool like a liberal but I'm a
conservative but I'm actually liberal
and margerie Taylor green doesn't really
engage in a lot of that but even there
at the end he's afraid of strong women
no he's afraid of going to prison and
getting caught for being The Bag Man for
the family and pedling American
influence and making tens of millions of
dollars that's that's what he's afraid
of he's not afraid of women that man
Hunter Biden might be afraid of a lot of
stuff he ain't afraid of women have you
looked at the tapes okay we've seen the
video tapes from the laptop it's just so
ah it's just so divorced from reality
and who does this work on who is this
supposed to work on nobody really
believes this stuff we all March along
and and and many people will will spout
off the talking points of white
privilege and feminism and patriarchy
but it's it's just because it's been
drilled into our heads since we were in
kindergarten it doesn't actually stir
men's souls or anything like that it
certainly doesn't persuade people on the
right stop using the Liberals language
I'm I'm actually lauding Marjorie Taylor
green here I I think it was a good
exchange but guys cut it out with the
feminist liberal White Privilege blah
blah blah clap trap just drop it good
grief the best exchange with Hunter was
Far and Away not with any of the members
of Congress it was it was with a
reporter who asked the question that was
on all of our minds let me make a
statement crack you normally smoke
Mr this is how Hunter Biden should be
dealt with on Capitol Hill okay Hunter
Biden is showing up to Capitol Hill not
to answer the legitimate questions of
congress not to face consequences for
his crimes that have been caught on tape
for years and years and
years some of which are not just Petty
personal sexual crimes and drug crimes
but but actually pretty serious
political crimes he is there to try to
win public sympathy he is there to make
the case that he's actually a victim of
a Witch Hunt he's there to to move the
polls and so knowing that understanding
that that's what this is really about
the way to deal with Hunter Biden is to
give as good as as as he does
okay the way to deal with Hunter Biden
is say hey hey man what's your favorite
kind of crack huh oh you think that's an
unfair question then come over here and
answer my fair
questions hey since we're all just
Jokers here today right no one's
actually going to be undertaking a
serious Congressional proceeding so yeah
what's your who what's your favorite
kind of hooker Hunter what do you wh
what's your favorite form of currency do
you like are you a big fan do you like
the Chinese currency or the Ukrainian
currency more because you made millions
of both so what which what do you like
what's your favorite oh you okay you
didn't well then let's talk let's go
into into your financial disclosures
let's go into all the shell
corporations let's go into your business
associates meeting with your father when
he was vice president of the United
States let's go into your father being
on 20 plus phone calls with the with the
business men you were shaking down all
around the world oh no we're not going
to do that okay well what what how long
do you like the crack pipes to be do you
like them to be two inches or 4 inches
love it absolutely great hilarious
exchange and it precisely the degree of
seriousness that that proceeding merits
now speaking of legislative
bodies big news for international
relations the San Francisco Board of
Supervisors has just voted 8 to3 in
favor of a ceasefire resolution for
Gaza
um following this vote a bunch of pro
Palestine white ladies uh cheered and
danced and chanted in the
[Applause]
Auditorium these middle-aged lesbians
are wearing Palestinian cafas it's so
perfect I just I love the whole thing
it's so great if Hamas had its DRS it
would nuke the entire city of San
Francisco and there are these people woo
free free Palestine yeah yeah that's
right Muhammad we're with you we're with
you but that's not even the most
ridiculous part the most ridiculous part
is that the San Francisco Board of
Supervisors thinks it has any
say over a millennia long ethnic
conflict on the other side of the
world when when is the Hamas Board of
Supervisors going to weigh in on the
needle exchange program Rams in San
Francisco when can we expect that vote
to take
place the there are problems in San
Francisco the people of San Francisco
elect their
representatives ostensively to solve the
the problems of the city of San
Francisco and they won't solve any of
those problems the problems are all
getting much much worse and people are
dying and they're not able to find
housing and the whole cities completely
fall into pot used to be one of the
great cities in America now it is just a
sewer and the San Francisco Board of
Supervisors rather than do the difficult
work of actually running their city and
trying to make things better and just
demonstrating basic competence of public
servants they they can't they actually
can't do that so they spend their
time in academic debates over what
should happen in conflicts that they
don't understand at all in places that
they probably couldn't even point to on
a map it's perfect it just
explains it it highlights so much the
state of American politics we are all
just living in a fantasy world while the
real world around us that we totally
neglect Falls to pot now there is a big
shift happening in foreign affairs you
might actually call it an Insurrection
but in this case it's an Insurrection
that the Liberals all around the world
are cheering on which we will get to in
one second first though it's no question
we're living in that clown world man the
characters in power are straight out of
a carnival basic Notions of right and
wrong Justice truth even reality itself
have been thrown out the window how are
we to make sense of it join Jonathan Pou
in the new four-part series end of the
world as he explains why the world as we
know it is ending how to survive it and
how we can plant the seeds for the next
world today Jonathan pjo is an
iconographer public speaker YouTuber and
good friend of Jordan Peterson you might
remember Jonathan from Jordan series on
Exodus now he's back and will draw upon
his deep knowledge of Christian
tradition stories myth ology and history
to explain the contradictions in our
society wacky phenomena and how this
pattern will reach its conclusion in end
of the world you will receive a
thoughtful framework to make sense of
these confusing times and a road map to
lead us out of the clown world and to
restore order all episodes are available
now exclusively on dailywire plus if you
have not become a member this is the
perfect time go to dailywire.com
subscribe unmask the Carneys and seeb on
the end watch end of the world today my
favorite comment yesterday is from Jim
lubka who says every single person who
got more of a punishment than a year of
probation Without Limits of travel needs
to make their appeal now to get their
sentenced reduced it's true the horn hat
guy from January 6th was thrown in the
Clank in in solitary I believe for part
of it for 41
months years on end and yet Ray EPS who
appears to have
instigated the invasion of the
capital he get
nothing a year probation never sees the
inside of a jail cell that's weird I
think all those guys should
appeal they should
sue they should at the very least point
out the absolute farce of the
prosecution of Ray apps who's definitely
not a fed I'm sure three people in
America still
believe turning to insurrections on
other parts of the
world there is a couet occurring right
now in Poland here's the headline this
is out of Politico the European edition
of
Politico police polish police arrest
members of parliament as Tusk versus
Duda rule of law battle heats up so this
is a rule of law battle according to
Politico between the Prime Minister and
the president Poland's new government
faces a huge struggle to unravel eight
years of rule by the Nationalist pis
party so there was a right-wing
government in Poland and then the
leftwing government takes power and what
are do they do immediately what they do
is they disband the public media they
suppress the media this if it were to
have happened under a right-wing
government you would hear calls for un
peacekeepers to show up you we would
hear that this was the total dismantling
of democracy in the country in fact
that's what you did hear when Hungarian
prime minister Victor Orban instituted
relatively modest reforms of the press
in Hungary happens in Poland they just
disband the entire public media and and
what do the liberal press do do they say
this is a threat to democracy no you
know what they they cheer it they say
well this is so good this is a
restoration of democracy then the piece
goes
on now you've got cops invading the
presidential Palace to arrest members of
parliament that's bad that's a cou day
Thai isn't it well not according to
Politico in a dramatic escalation of
Poland's battle to restore rule of
law the police entered the country's
presidential Palace on Tuesday evening
and took two members of parliament into
custody who had been hiding under the
protection of President Andre Duda after
being sentenced to prison for terms for
abuses of
power this is the the battle to restore
rule of law and the way that we're going
to restore rule of law is we're going to
ban the press and we're going to invade
the presidential Palace and we're going
to arrest members of parliament that's
how we're going to does that sound like
restoring rule of
law doesn't to me it sounds like totally
ending the rule of
law but this is because one man's
insurrectionist is another man's
defender of democracy you know that
phrase the libs always say they say one
man's Freedom Fighter is another man's
terrorist and they they say this to blur
the distinction between terrorists and
Freedom Fighters to say well from from
our perspective you know these jihadis
in the Middle East they're terrorists
but from their perspective they're
Freedom
Fighters but as with the the libs always
trying to blur distinctions distinctions
between men and women distinctions
between one country and another country
it's just totally bogus because
terrorism has a meaning terrorism is
defined in large part by whether or not
you target civilians to achieve
political ends that's a really basic
definition of
terrorism and you can measure that you
can say are people targeting civilians
to achieve political ends okay well that
would be an act of terrorism same
here is a government
um contradicting what the people want
what the People Express is the
government uh upending established norms
and traditions and even
laws if so that's not very Democratic is
it you know that in Colorado they say
that to defend democracy we need to
prevent the people from voting for
Donald Trump who's the single most
popular candidate in the presidential
race that just can't be true it's only
true if you if you redefine democracy to
be deprived of all of its
meaning it's a reminder I I'm I'm not
just here uh complaining about what's
going on in Eastern Europe without a
fact I know that that whatever we say
about this is not going to affect what
happens and the way that there is a coua
in in Poland but it's just a reminder
you're going to hear a lot about
insurrections and coupet and blah blah
blah for the next 12
months you got to try to pull yourself
out of that bubble you got to try to
pull yourself out of the fish tank you
know the the water in which we little
fishes are swimming you got to you've
got to try to get some perspective here
and recognize that the media are not
neutral that the system of laws in our
civil government they're not Eternal
they're changing they're always kind of
changing jurist Prudence the way that we
interpret the law that's changing a lot
too the language that we use it's not
totally objective and it's not eternal
it's constantly being manipulated to to
scramble up our brains and to change the
way that we perceive the world and when
they huff and puff and scream and they
say all the anyone who supports the
Conservative candidate they're just
upending democracy I might listen I
might not be a republican but I want
there to be a strong Republican party in
this country just not that kind of
Republican not the kind of Republican
it's just
bogus it's just manipulative nonsense
and we've got to be able to see that and
stand firm and and if we're at the point
right now where the Republican the
conservative members of Congress are
just blindly belching up left-wing
talking points they don't they have no
idea even what they're saying it's going
to be very very difficult to gain that
kind of perspective and to fight back
speaking of our
rights the All Souls
choir that's an important
song uh for your religious ed ification
and your political edification borrowing
words from Stacy Abrams Melissa duny and
Ida B Wells coming to a
leftist church community near you take
it
away all
right we live in the right
St our
right on where we were
home
our
depend on how land our
[Music]
arise
ID our gender our rights depend on the
lawers we can
[Music]
on whe the
criminal hold on
of the last one's true your rights
actually do depend on whether or not
you've been convicted of certain crimes
and if you have then you do actually
forfeit some rights yeah and if your
will generally match your gender
something would have had to go seriously
wrong for you know your big Husky Hank
shows up to the ID place and they list
you as a woman on your ID that all right
depend this is being sung by the All
Souls choir because there is always a
relation between church and state
there's always a relation between the
political order and religion it's an old
it's an older clip this clip is from I
think a year ago maybe a little bit more
than a year ago expect more of this
expect forget about this being sung in
some room and going viral on Twitter
there are going to be couldn't you just
see the military parades going by in the
new Rainbow regime where you've got the
the dictator some kind of androgynous
dictator just standing there upright
making some weirdo salute and then just
rainbow tanks go on you all right step
and because all politics ultimately is
theological and uh this this kind of
propaganda seeps in everywhere you know
we we make fun of the North Korean crazy
Communist Regime for brainwashing people
and the people behaving in this totally
bizarre
way conservative members of Congress
screaming Furious about white privilege
and girl bosses not being being able to
speak
enough I wonder
how how's the brainwashing going here
how's the how's the regime change going
here maybe maybe a coup d' Daya really
has taken place I don't think it was the
horn hat guy that let it though the rest
of the show continues now you don't want
to miss it become a member use code
nolles kwl has a check out for two
months free on all annual
[Music]
plans